I have no idea how to make a funny
introduction for this video,
so instead I'm going to give you a quick
slideshow of cool,
awesome slavek stuff.
Go.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the Slavic
languages.
They may not get as much attention as
the romance languages and the Germanic
languages,
but the Slavic languages are an
important family of languages with $315
million native speakers and covering
over half the area of Europe.
That includes Eastern Europe,
the balcones as well as the European
part of Russia,
and of course the Asian part of Russia
as well,
Slavic languages or a branch of the Indo
European language family.
If we go all the way back to the
beginning that there was a language
called [inaudible],
Indo European,
which is the language from which all
Indo European languages descended.
That includes the romance languages.
That dramatic language is to enjoy
running in languages and of course the
Slavic languages as well as others.
One language that developed from Indo
European was pro tow Bulto Slavic.
That language is the ancestor of both
the Baltic languages and the Slavic
languages,
but the Slavic language family broke off
from Provo Balto slavek around 1,500
to 1000 bce.
The language then underwent a 2000 year
period of gradual development,
but during that time it remained a
single unified language around 500 ce.
There was a language called protos
slavic that would later split and would
give birth to all of the modern Slavic
languages of today.
Protos slavek was the ancestor of all
Slavic languages.
The time between 500 cm,
1000 ce was called the common slavek
period,
and during this period,
protos slavek began to diverge into
dialects and that Slavic people migrated
over a wider area.
Those differences increased by about
$1,000.
Seed there were distinct west Slavek,
east Slavic and South Slavic languages.
Those three languages would later become
three branches of the Slavic language
family,
and the dialects of those languages
would become the different languages in
each branch.
The East Slavic languages include
Russian,
Ukrainian,
and Bella Lucien,
which is sometimes called White Russian,
South Slavic language family includes
Serbo,
Croatian,
Bulgarian Macedonian,
which are very similar,
Slovenian,
and also the liturgical language known
as old church.
Slavonic slavonic just means Slavic.
The West Slavic languages include
Polish,
Czech,
Slovak,
Serbian,
which is a minority language in eastern
Germany,
job in which is a minority language.
In Poland,
the Slavic languages are much closer to
each other then the languages of other
into European language families.
That's because protos slavek split into
different languages relatively recently
compared to other language families like
Germanic and romance.
Some people claimed that all slavic
languages are mutually intelligible to a
large degree,
but that's not really true,
but from what I understand,
the speaker of any Slavic language can
probably find a way to make some sort of
simple conversation with the speaker of
any other Slavic language or most other
Slavic languages.
That doesn't mean they can understand
everything,
but that means when they're talking face
to face,
maybe they can find a way to communicate
and within each of those three branches
of the language family,
there seems to be quite a lot of mutual
intelligibility.
For example,
the East slavek branch,
here are some average figures from
native speakers statements on the
Internet,
so for Russian speakers,
Bella Lucien is about 74 percent
intelligible and it's spoken for them an
85 percent intelligible in its written
form.
Ukrainian is 50 percent intelligible and
it's spoken for them and 85 percent
intelligible in its written form,
but in both cases there were also a
transitional dialects.
For example,
the Ukrainian is more similar to the
Russian dialects in the south of the
country rather than the standard
language which is based on dialects of
the north,
so speakers of those southern Russian
dialects might have an easier time
communicating with someone from Ukraine.
Here's another example from a lang focus
viewer named anointed fighter.
He says,
I'm a native Bulgarian speaker.
I can understand 80 percent Serbian and
80 percent Russian,
especially if they are written Czech
Slovakia and Slovenia and I can get 60
percent and from Polish only 40 percent
to Bulgaria and Serbia and are both part
of the South Slavic branch so he can
understand 80 percent of Serbian,
but he can also understand 80 percent of
Russian even though it's in the East
slavek branch.
Slavic was still a single unified
language in the ninth century when the
first known slavic writings were
written.
These writings were written in old
church slavonic slavonic just means
slavek.
Remember it was the first slavek
literary language and it was
standardized by the Saint Cyril and
methodius so that they could translate
the Bible and other religious works into
the Slavic language and they could
minister to the slabs and convert them
to Christianity.
At this point,
there were slavic dialects,
but they were still relatively close to
each other.
So old church slavonic was widely
understood.
Old Church slavonic went on to become
the language of religious ceremony for
the eastern Orthodox Church and the
eastern Catholic church,
and it's still used by many churches
today.
One of the writing system,
Cyril and methodius used to write old
church slavonic was the cyrillic script,
so the word cyrillic comes from the
Saints Names Cyril.
The cyrillic script was adapted from the
old Greek script with some additional
letters to represent sounds found in old
church slavonic that were not found in
Greek today.
There are Slavic languages written in
cyrillic script and there are also those
written in variations of the Latin
script.
Those written in the cyrillic script
tend to be for cultures in which the
eastern Orthodox or eastern Catholic
church are dominant.
Those written in the Latin script tend
to be for cultures in which the Roman
Catholic church is dominant.
One of the common features of Slavic
languages aside from Bulgarian and
Macedonian is that the nouns and
pronouns are highly inflected.
Have many grammatical cases.
Grammatical case means that the noun or
a pronoun changes form depending on its
function in the sentence in English.
The only example we have of this is with
the pronouns.
For example,
I is the subject for him and me is the
object form,
but nouns can have multiple forums like
this as well.
If they have grammatical cases,
Slavic languages have up to seven
different grammatical cases.
Let's look at an example for the Polish
word for bottle with Telefonica
Boutiquey hotel.
It's a Teleco Teleco.
We tell them say,
so the word bottle changes form
depending on which case it's being used.
I won't go through each one and say
which case it is,
but you can see that the form of the
noun changes for people whose native
language is not a highly inflected
language with grammatical cases like
that.
This can make learning a slavic
language,
a challenge.
You not only have to memorize those
different forums,
but when you're speaking,
you have to constantly be aware of which
form the word should be,
which function the word is fulfilling in
the sentence.
Another characteristic of Slavic
languages is that they don't have
articles.
That means like the or are in English,
and again the exception is Bulgarian and
Macedonian.
For some reason the lack of grammatical
cases and the presence of articles might
make Bulgarian Macedonian easier to
learn,
but the most widely studied slavic
language is Russian and that's probably
because it's the most widely spoken.
There are $150 million native speakers
of Russian,
and if we include second language
speakers,
there are $260 million proficient
speakers.
The second most widely spoken is Polish
with around $40 million native speakers.
The third most widely spoken is
Ukrainian with about $30 million
speakers.
The fourth is Serbo Croatian with about
19 million speakers and yes,
I know some people consider those to be
separate languages,
but I will leave that topic for a
different video for now.
The fifth is checked with 10 million
people and of course there are numerous
other important slavic languages to
really.
There's so much to say about the various
different Slavic languages that I can't
talk about it all in one video,
but please stay tuned for future videos
in which I talk about specific Slavic
languages.
So that brings us to the end of this
video.
But the question of the day for Slavic
language speakers is can you communicate
with the speakers of different slavic
languages and if so,
which ones?
Is it just the ones in your language
branch,
like East Slavek or South Slavic,
or can you communicate with the speakers
in other branches as well?
Let us know in the comments down below
and other people you can comment about
whatever you want.
Alright.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.